all right what's going on guys this is
rob and we are here with the conclusion
of the 10 deaths of wolverine and really
the lives and deaths of wolverine is
completely done uh so in the the last
video that we did for the deaths of
wolverine we were talking about how
omega wolverine was basically making its
way to kokoa now omega wolverine was
basically a version of wolverine from
the future that had a kind of merger
between phalanx technology or a
techno-organic virus essentially as well
as wolverine himself and his healing
factor is what basically allowed him to
utilize the capabilities of the phalanx
without actually succumbing to its
influence because remember with the
phalanx being a techno-organic virus
it's not necessarily in the same way as
like cable it is to a degree but the
difference between like cable and the
phalanx is that the tendon organic virus
as it's pertaining to cable is more of
like a technological cancer right it's
literally just eating away at his body
all the time or at least trying to and
that's why he's not as powerful as he
could be because he devotes his
telekinesis and his telepathy to keeping
the virus from destroying him with the
phalanx they are a techno-organic
organism but they're also sentient and
so this future version of wolverine is
literally keeping a sentient virus from
trying to destroy him while also using
its capabilities now in that fight at
the end of the last issue that moore
mchagert had blasted omega wolverine
with the gun that was used by fords to
shut down her powers which in turn shut
down the powers of wolverine and that
where more of a taggart's ability is to
basically die and then come back to life
in like essentially a new a new timeline
basically that she's effectively
immortal and is always resurrected of
course that's not necessarily a power
that she has now now that she she was
she's powerless uh that version of
wolverine lost his healing factor and so
the phalanx completely took over his
body and that's what we're dealing with
here we're dealing with a version of
wolverine whose consciousness is
somewhat there but the phalanx is
basically overtaking him and the mission
is to kill charles xavier now more
important than that this phalanx has its
own mission because remember this is
very very like terminator-esque in terms
of what's going on here right now and
there is a kind of john connor that
comes in the form of cerebral and the
reason why is because if this version of
wolverine if the phalanx version is able
to access cerebro it'd be like skynet
going online he could just tap into
everything and basically the phalanx
would completely and totally conquer the
world like that like in an instant right
phones computers tablets the whole nine
yards and even start infecting people
and so the phalanx would be able to take
over the world and the phalanx
themselves are always on a mission of
conquest they always have been they're
like the borg from star trek right
they're always looking to assimilate new
technologies and biological organisms
into themselves and so that's why the
response of sage and talking to beast is
you have to isolate the cradle right
where cerebral is located you have to
isolate this from the rest of the
mainframe because if it's connected and
that phalanx wolverine is able to tap
into the mainframe he'll access the
cradle and then it's game over and so of
course beast works on doing that while
he's doing that sage takes the sword
that had previously been given to her by
wolverine right the cerebral sword and
basically reprograms it now while that's
going on the only real stopgap measure
you have for omega wolverine is the
other wolverines right is laura kinney
and it's dakin and it's gaby doing what
they can they haven't necessarily
alerted the entire uh the entire island
because one they don't want to freak
everybody out and two this is really
more of like a personal fight but as
things continue to go on right as the
fight goes on further and further and
even when dakin goes to punch like omega
wolverine and almost gets infected with
a techno-organic virus himself had his
healing factor not kicked in and
basically fought it off uh that
ultimately it's kind of this realization
they can't really do it on their own and
so what you end up getting here in this
really really cool moment which i
absolutely love is you have like
basically wolverine prime we can call
him that or wolverine facing off against
omega wolverine now when wolverine
initially shows up here he presents the
watch from the 10 lives of wolverine
video that we did the one that was given
him given to him by that version of
charles xavier through the timeline and
he was basically told look it was given
to us by someone that basically told us
never to lose our way you obviously have
right you have lost your way whichever
version of me you are but you have lost
your way and you are ultimately no
longer me you are just some corrupted
version of yourself and so now basically
i have to destroy you
right i'm going to have to end you here
and this is a really really cool moment
because it's wolverine versus omega
wolverine but more so than that and this
is one of the biggest things about this
and why i love this so much historically
when it comes to wolverine fighting like
these arch nemesis of his or like these
major villains or something like that
the the emphasis is always on how
wolverine's past has somehow come back
to bite him in the ass that's basically
what it is right like when deacon first
popped up that dakin was the son he
didn't know he had and it was the fact
that wolverine had just never sought him
out that left dakin to hate his father
so much now of course a lot of that dust
settled uh and so it's one of those
things where like the relationship
between dakin and wolverine is what it
is because it's wolverine not knowing he
was there but that's an aspect of his
past coming back to bite him and it's
just a continuous element of wolverine
in this instance it's his future he's
literally fighting against the person
that he feels he will inevitably become
right this version of himself in the
far-flung future that was sent back here
in an effort to try to find some way to
destroy more mctaggart and then became
corrupted by the phalanx virus that he
allowed to be attached to himself for
the purpose of helping him achieve his
goal and now it's the screwed up twisted
version of him now what marvel also does
here and this is a this is a really
really cool thing what marvel does here
is they take the cerebral sword and they
modify it now this is a this is wildly
huge because you're going to see this
become a major focus of marvel going
into the future so you will likely see
this as just a thing that may reappear
somewhere along the line or at least it
becomes a talking point like a really
good example is the muramasa blade that
when when wolverine had gone on this
path where he was basically tracking
down everybody who did him wrong and
writing and really just scratching names
off the list is really what it was that
he had taken the cerebral sword he had
it created had a portion of his soul put
inside the sword so that if it was used
on him it would basically shut down his
healing factor like i mean end it i
don't mean i don't mean like it would
shut it down temporarily like the
carbonadium sword or any form of
carbeneum does i mean like the muramasa
blade will end his healing factor it'll
no longer be there and uh and then you
can just kill wolverine by virtually any
conventional meme as long as you can get
past his adamantium skeleton but he took
the sword and he gave it to cyclops and
every once in a while in marvel comics
while you may not necessarily see the
muramasa blade itself you'll see
reference to it when wolverine's talking
about the ways in which he can actually
be killed permanently the muramasa blade
will be one of those points that he
brings up this sword is very much going
to be the same way and the reason why is
because with beast kind of asking the
question okay sage like what are you up
to she's like i'm a living computer
right like that's literally my job i'm
gonna go hack something that what she's
done is she's taken this sword and she's
modified it basically reprogrammed it
because it is a technological sword
she's reprogrammed it and basically
turned it into a weapon that can destroy
the phalanx now whether or not this will
be used on the phalanx as a whole i
don't entirely know but it is a weapon
that can be used against anything that
has a machine component that seems to be
the case and so what this does is it
basically leads to this this again kind
of a continuation of this fight between
wolverine and omega wolverine and the
reality here is it is equal in some ways
and unequal in others right because they
both bring something to the table so
modern day wolverine brings a kind of of
youth in comparison to like this older
version of himself that of course his
older version doesn't necessarily have
it's like modern wolverine versus old
man logan that kind of a thing and he
brings a kind of ferociousness to the
table what the omega wolverine brings
now especially since it's now covered in
in phalanx is it brings one the ability
of his older self to have experience
right to know when to when to slow down
when to move faster but it also brings a
just kind of ruthlessness in the sense
that because it's now mostly machine and
really that that essence that spiritual
essence or the mind of wolverine is
basically gone ah then it'll just keep
fighting and fighting and fighting it's
like just fighting a machine version of
wolverine it won't stop and it'll
seemingly never run out of energy and
now it's got and it's got adamantium and
so in response to that there's no way
this fight can continue to go on in its
current form with wolverine coming out
on top it's never gonna happen if this
fight goes on longer wolverine's going
to die at the hands of his omega self
and that's one of the things that was
even recognized by like deakin and laura
and uh and gabby early on in the fight
as they were like we can't actually
defeat this thing like we can keep it at
bay but we cannot destroy it and that's
when sage comes running up with a
cerebral sword throws it to him and then
of course when wolverine gets it plunges
the sword into mega wolf reign which
basically destroys the phalanx on his
body there's not one trace of it left
but that phalanx is completely and
totally gone but that's why i say this
sword is important and you will likely
see it in the future of the x-men comics
going forward because it's a sword that
can be used to one defeat the phalanx or
and two really anything with a
cybernetic or a technological component
to it which really begs the question
what happens if somebody uses this sword
on like apocalypse or something like
that you know if they use they use a
sword unlike a celestial or something
right is the the programming of of sage
on you know is it powerful enough to
overcome that level of power i'd say
probably not against the celestial right
all they'd have to do is just make the
sword just a regular sword right with a
wave of their hands
and that would be it but against someone
like apocalypse it would probably work
it would probably be able to destroy him
he's not 100 machine but he does use
celestial technology right a good
portion of them is celestial technology
not only that this sword could
potentially be used to cure cable of the
techno-organic virus should it ever
return so it is a cool thing but
nonetheless of course what this does is
the island takes the body of omega
wolverine and basically just kind of
brings it inside the island itself which
essentially means at some future point
in time that version of wolverine could
return not in the phalanx form but like
if this modern version of wolverine dies
and for some reason they can't resurrect
him then it's just like use the bones of
his old self right and that's basically
it uh but but everybody's just kind of
hanging around and they're just sort of
talking at the green lagoon and they're
having some drinks and chilling and just
general conversation and whatnot and
wolverine in a lot of ways isn't
necessarily you know really a part of
this party and when they're asking like
why are you so grumpy and why are you so
gloomy then he's like if anything what
i've learned over the course of my life
is we are beset on all sides by like
fights that's just the way that it is
right it's people coming after us all
the time and they're like calm down man
right we're all having a good time
everybody's chilling of course he's also
referencing the fact that sabretooth is
still basically strung down in the
prison beneath krakowa which as far as
i'm aware i think he escapes from in his
own his own solo series which takes
place after 10 lives of wolverine but
there's also this conversation that
happens with you know between beast and
sage where they talk about the nature of
wolverine and what's cool is that sage
says she says so i guess it turns out
the mutants don't always lose and b says
sage there's a very important but to
acknowledge here and he says the only
reason we won is wolverine he's the
medicine the penicillin shall we say
required to fight fight an incursion on
the timeline fight the deadly infection
of ai fight fight fight and sage says i
suppose he is the best there is and b
says he's the best he is because he's
unlike the high-minded and ideological
driven mutants on the council who
supposedly guide krakowa and worry
endlessly over diplomatic nonsense he's
the best there is because he's a savage
killer i don't love him but he is the
sharpest tool with which we do our
cutting and sage says i see that you've
completely ignored my contributions but
ego aside i don't like where your mind's
at and b says oh please don't clutch
your pearls and feign offense i'm simply
pointing out a truth that most would
prefer not to acknowledge in the end
force wins stabbing [ __ ] is what saves
the world and again that's the a really
amazing point because it's kind of what
i've always said right violence is not
always the answer but it is a answer and
it's usually a very effective one but
the other part of this and probably the
most significant part of this is that
beast does not see wolverine as anything
other than a tool to be used to fight a
fight that's it you wouldn't give him a
job that requires anything other than
like sneak into a place kill some people
and then leave or fight some force head
on and that's really really interesting
because it means that where wolverine is
now he'll never move beyond this as far
as beast is concerned and so what you
end up basically doing is switching over
to a cemetery and something that by all
standards of measurement shouldn't be
able to happen and we don't know how it
did but basically
while you're going through this cemetery
a hand reaches out of a grave and more
mctaggart comes back in what looks like
her 11th life now that shouldn't be the
case more mctaggart should be dead right
remember her mutant power was gone it
was taken when she was shot by the gun
that was created by ford to shut down
mutant powers what this looks like is
that more mctaggart's mutant power to
basically be resurrected only kicks in
when she dies and i know a lot of people
would just kind of be like well yeah
obviously i mean why would she resurrect
while she was alive right she just
suddenly wakes up in a different body no
no here's what i mean so when it comes
to powers of marvel comics you you sure
have like all kinds of powers right like
storm can manipulate the elements and
ice man can make stuff cold and cyclops
can open his eyes to another dimension
that lets all this concussive energy
pour through but powers themselves are
only ever arranged in two categories
active powers and passive powers so an
act of power is something like
nightcrawler teleporting right he has to
actively do it he knows where he wants
to be he teleports to the brimstone
dimension and comes out at his
destination a passive power is someone
like spider-man's healing factor right
where peter parker is injured and then
his healing factor kicks in and he
recovers but those powers are always
active those passive powers are always
engaged in some form or fashion right
that you contract colds you can track
flues different things like that that
healing factor is always going on with
something like more mccaggart in this
instance is kind of a third form that
we've just never really heard of before
right that it's this this thing where
her ability to resurrect whenever she
dies it's just a power that kicks in
it's not active because she can't
actively decide to come back to life
once she's dead
but it's not really passive in the
traditional sense uh maybe it is to a
degree right in the sense that like it
automatically happens but can the body
process a healing factor if the body is
physically dead but if the body's
basically gone like with wolverine for
example it's a little weird because you
know with healing people with healing
factors it doesn't necessarily work that
way their healing factor usually
prevents them from dying but in those
instances when something like uh like
peter parker has died in some alternate
reality story somewhere that his healing
factor stops activating it stops
existing his body decomposes and it
corrodes and it becomes one with the
earth and then whatever happens after
that plants grow there i don't i don't
know like i mean who cares but like his
healing factor stops working it's not as
though his healing factor keeps
operating and his body you know
maintains its youthful appearance even
though he's dead so again it's you know
with usually with any kind of a power
once you die your power goes with you
your power doesn't continue on you know
it's it's just kind of a weird thing
which really begs the question what
would happen if there were a story where
like somebody took the visor off of
cyclops and then shot him in the back of
the head and then opened his eyes would
literally just non-stop concussive blast
come out of his eyes for eternity until
somebody closes them like is that what
would happen i don't know as morbid as
it sounds i'd be interested in finding
out
but this is basically some kind of a
hybrid power it's cool right i mean if
this is really the case that more
mctaggart's ability that being shot with
this uh with this gun by forge didn't
negate her power because her power is
not active but it's not passive it just
activates whenever she dies and then
essentially goes into remission that
maybe she really is legitimately
immortal right maybe she really is just
she'll never ever die and there's no way
to truly shut her power down i don't
know but it's really cool and i'm really
excited to find out so with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this to an
end thank you all for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace